[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que tu arrives à faire ça
je les mettais tout mouillé maintenant
comme ça en levant le droit
comme beaucoup de monde vous pensez que
le paracétamol doliprane ça résout tous
les problèmes pas vraiment je vous dise
ah bon alors si ça passe pas après un
doliprane n'est pas non plus un
traitement miracle si ça persie si les
symptômes persistent y on se sent pas
bien alors qu'on a pris du doliprane pas
un doliprane mais du doliprane à ce
moment là il faut consulter le médecin
faut savoir que doliprane ça n'est pas
une friandise autrement dit c'est du
paracétamol et du paracétamol c'est à la
fois un antalgique donc pour lutter
contre la douleur et un antipyrétique
pour faire baisser en cas de fièvre mais
ça peut être toxique aussi notamment
pour le foie et il ya des gens qui
prennent des dizaines de doliprane par
jour ça peut entraîner des problèmes
hépatiques gravissime donc le doliprane
on peut en prendre si on est adulte du
doliprane 1000 mais on n'en prend pas
plus de quatre par jour en moyenne
[Musique]
autant
way bush
c'est noël jamet champion du monde du
cri du cochon et normand mais attendez à
l'existant être compétition
[Applaudissements]
béchir c'est une blague
[Musique]
by sleep et bizzbee
présentatrice des journaux sur tf1 les
vendre
célibataire pense pas que c'est parce
que tu es moche
mais c'est juste parce que tu as comme
le dernier gâteaux apéro tout le monde
veut mais personne n'ose des bonnes
pioches